almost a week since a ferocious storm
choked this Frozen land Buffalo is
starting to churn again the main airport
is back open and the roads are too a
travel ban lifted freeing people to move
around but even as temperatures rise and
conditions thaw the emotions and the
anger are raw and just explain what the
the last week's been like for you a
living hell an absolute living hell like
nobody cares for six days Chris was
trapped inside by snow packed so tightly
by the wind she couldn't open her front
door she says the local government
abandoned her and her neighbors yes it's
the first day I went out
and today I came out to dry shovel and I
called my other my other daughter and
she came over and helped me we were
doing this and that's when that man
thank you
gave him saved us that's how I feel
about money you've saved us
and why should companies be digging out
when we live in the city yeah yeah take
care they take care of every place else
but here and like because they say this
is the Poor Side of the city
of the 39 people now confirmed to have
died in Buffalo
many lived in the most deprived part of
town and the majority were Black Or
Hispanic Monique Alexander was a 52 year
old who doted on her grandchildren she
told her daughter on Christmas Eve she
was nipping out for a short while and
would be back soon she never returned
she was found a few hundred yards from
her front door frozen to death a
stranger brought her body and placed it
under the awning of this jewelry shop so
she could be found and retrieved more
easily
as the clear-up continues the head of
the local government says he expects the
death toll to rise
unfortunately there are families in this
community
who
still have not been able to identify
where a loved one is they're missing and
we do have still
John Doe's
and eventually those family members are
going to find out the worst news
possible several of those killed froze
to death in their cars some question
whether they were given adequate warning
before the storm hit the post-mortems on
the many victims continued and the
post-mortem 2 and the authorities
handling of this crisis Martha calners
Sky News Buffalo